I Don't Wanna Dance  special guest in the audience tonight  legendary record executive Mr Clyde  Davis  the voice is gone what you start the  show tonight no talking back I'm Your  Mother  [Music]  [Applause]  what's your name again Whitney Elizabeth  Houston  he really loves me  my dream  sing what I want to sing be how I want  to be  just being an audience as I can  a common criticism of you your music  isn't black enough  look I don't know how to sing black I  don't know how to sing white either  foreign  I might have just heard the greatest  voice of Her generation  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  maybe maybe it's Gotta Have a hook the  hook yeah  I'll give it a hook